everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today
so today let's look at a problem
palindrome partitioning
so we're given a string s and we want to
partition it in such a way that
every single sub-string of the partition
is a palindrome and we want to return
all
possible ways that we can partition it
in
like by following this rule and if you
don't remember a palindrome is basically
a string
that if you reverse it it's the exact
same string
so one thing to notice is no matter what
string we're given it's
possible to partition it in this way why
is that the case
because in this case we have a a b
we know that any any single character
like
a is a palindrome right if you reverse a
you get a
any character including b is a
palindrome right
reverse it you get b so one way to
partition this is take
each character and separate it right and
that's what the first partition over
here is right each character by itself
so are there any other ways to partition
this other than just
this single way well if you take the
first two characters
you see that that is also a palindrome
right a
a reversa is still a a and of course b
by itself we know any single character
is definitely a palindrome
so for the second partition we'll have
two sub strings right
a and b so then this is our result
because we cannot have any other sub
strings that are phalan drums right
a b is not a palindrome if you reverse
it we get b a that's not the same string
if you take this and you reverse it you
get b a
a that's not a palindrome so the brute
force way in this case
to solve this problem happens to also be
the main way to solve this problem which
is
backtracking so we are going to use
backtracking to solve this problem and
what we're going to do is create
every single possible way we could
partition this
and then check if those partitions form
palindromes and if they do we are going
to add them to our
result list right because ultimately we
want to re
we want a list that has every single way
to partition this
while maintaining palindromes so for the
first
partition we have three choices do you
see what they
are if we want a first partition well
the first partition can either be a by
itself right
so a by itself which is if we just took
the first
character and said that that was one
partition another
partition is double a right if we just
took the first two characters
as our first partition or the last one
obviously if we just took the entire
string as our first partition
now we will check is this a palindrome
how are we going to check well we can
start comparing the first
and last characters right and we see
that well they're not even equal
right so this is not a palindrome so
we are not going to continue on this
branch
or on this path for our depth for search
tree but we know that this
by itself is a palindrome right so this
is going to be our first partition now
we're going to take the remaining
characters
a and b and try to partition them
right so for one partition of those
remaining characters we could get a
single a if we took this first one
another partition we could get
is a b if we took
both of these characters but we look at
the first character and last character
this is not a palindrome
this is a palindrome but this is not a
palindrome
so we don't have to continue on this
path and from
here we know we already took the first
two characters as our first partition
so we only have one choice for our
second partition
and that's just the character b and we
know a single character by itself
does form a partition and we also know
that we have no more remaining
characters right we already took the
first three characters
so what this tells us is this is one
possible way to partition
to make sure that all the substrings are
palindromes right both of these
substrings are palindromes so this is
one possible uh solution so now the only
path for us to continue we can't do this
and we can't do this
and we cannot do this anymore we don't
have any more characters
so we can continue this one how many
choices do we have well we took the
first two a's
right so now we only have one choice and
that's going to be the b
so we for our third partition in
this line is going to be b so this one
had
two uh partitions right two strings
this one has three and all of them
happen to be palindrome so this is
also a possible solution so that's how
you basically solve this problem
with backtracking it's not super
efficient right it's going to be at
least 2 to the power of
n because we're brute forcing it but now
let me show you the code
so let's have our result this is what's
going to store all of the partitions
that we
create all the possible partitions let's
also have
a variable called part this is this
basically stands for partitions this is
our
current partition right so if our
current partition happens to be
this this is just going to be the single
partition the result is going to be what
stores the partitions right so this will
possibly have you know multiple
partitions in it
and now i'm going to create a nested
function depth first search for
our br our backtracking the only thing
i'm going to pass into it is i the index
of the character
we're currently at and so since this
function is
nested inside this function these two
variables as well as
s the string are going to be accessible
in this even if we don't pass them into
it
so since this is a recursive function
first thing we check is the base case so
if i
happens to be out of bound so if it's
greater than or equal to the length of
the input string
s what are we going to do well in that
case
the same thing that we did over here
right we knew that we had
our a valid partition and we had no more
characters to add so in that case we
know that this
is a possible solution so what i'm going
to do here is basically to our result
i'm going to append the current
partition that we have formed
but not only that i'm going to clone it
because we know
or rather i'm gonna copy it because we
know if we end up
in a different recursive call making
changes to this variable there's only
one part partition variable so it's not
like there are multiple
partitions being created we only have a
single one so every time
we append to result we have to make a
copy of it
and after we do that we can return
because this is our base case
if we haven't reached the last index
what can we do well we can iterate
through
every other character in our string
right so
we're going to start at i and keep going
until we get to the
end of the string and
for this meaning so this is going to be
our sub string right this is
every possible substring and we want to
know is it a palindrome
so so the indices are going to tell us
if
from a string s starting at index i all
the way to j
we're going to check every possible
string i'm going to add one to j
to get rid of the off by one error and i
want to
know is this a string is this a
palindrome
i'm also going to pass in the indices i
and j
so we know what our left and right
boundaries are and actually since we are
passing in these
boundaries we don't actually need to
create a substring we can just pass
s itself so we want to know is s a
palindrome if you take it
to start at index i and end at index
j is this a palindrome and so if it
happens to be a palm drum i'll actually
write this helper function later we'll
just assume we have it now so if this
happens to be a palindrome what can we
do
we can to our partition we can add this
string so s from index i
to index j get rid of the off by 1 error
we can add this
so this is our current partition and we
want to keep
because we know s this substring is a
palindrome
and so now we can recursively do our
depth first search
looking for additional palindromes and
of course we'll start at j
plus one because that's going to be the
next
character and after we do our recursive
function we have to clean
up so since we know we only have one
single partition variable
after we have added this and added the
substring and then ran our debt for
search
looking for all possible additional
partitions
after that we can take the string that
we just added over here and then pop
that from our partition list and that's
actually our entire
depth for search function you notice we
have our base case when we go out of
bounds
and with this loop we are generating
every single possible substring right
from i to j
we're checking if it's a palindrome if
it is then we're recursively continuing
our depth for search
if it's not a palindrome then we're just
skipping that substring altogether and
going to the next
iteration of the loop so that's our
entire function and the only thing left
for us to do is to actually
call it so debt for search will pass in
zero because we know that's the start
index
and then what we're going to do is
return result
and before i forget we know we have to
actually write this helper function that
we called before we even wrote it so
let's write that really quickly is
palindrome
it'll accept a string and it'll accept
left and right boundaries so we just
have to check if it's a palindrome
so while left is less than right
we'll check if the character at the left
position
doesn't equal the character at the right
position that means
it's not a palindrome so we can return
false if it
if they are equal then we can update our
left and right pointer so add one to
left
and subtract one from the right pointer
and if this loop this entire loop
executes and all the characters actually
were equal
then we'll exit the loop and then we can
return true because that means it
is a palindrome and now let me just run
it to prove to you that it works
and hopefully it's somewhat efficient
yep it runs perfectly and
it is pretty efficient so i hope this
was helpful
if you enjoyed please like and subscribe
it supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon